as campaign launches go it was hardly
smooth
a live audio conversation with Twitter's
Elon Musk now it's quiet which didn't
quite work at least not at the start all
right great so let's see
a hint at an incompetent candidate so I
think we're back online here well the
spin of course was that Rhonda Santos
broke the internet so many were wanting
to tune in that is if less than a
million is so many I have Governor
Santos uh make this a stark announcement
at times Twitter's music filling the
void
later on more traditional friendly Fox
News he brushed it off it did break the
Twitter space and so we're really
excited with the enthusiasm and laid out
his policies yeah we will construct the
border wall ripping out uh Biden's
anti-American energy policies against
woke ideology and against the
sexualization of children the woke mind
virus is basically a form of cultural
Marxism
[Applause]
[Music]
this election cycle will prompt
well then America is in for a ride
woke way
Warwick did Governor buy a landslide
here those who fear his politics are
louder than those who love it
his policy for Florida and pitch for
America is that the nation has lost its
way and needs to return to conservative
values it's the so-called book ban which
resonates deeply removing many deemed to
be overly sexualized from schools
but there is a counter to that fear over
books and you'll find it among some of
those who are in Florida's classrooms
like Denise Supreme he touts that we're
the free state of Florida and I don't
understand how he could possibly say
that when you are restricting the rights
well what about all the other parents
that want their children to be exposed
to ideas of All Sorts so their children
can grow
you know and befriend and be kind and
compassionate and empathetic drag queens
are a bunch of pedophiles hide your kids
we're back here and away from all the
noise the focus now for Rhonda Santos is
in this building donors meetings over
the next few days persuading them that
it wasn't a failed launch that he
deserves their money and that he can win
the presidency on the right right now
it's Trump versus DeSantis Mark Stone
Sky News in Florida